.
LET'S HOPE THERE IS NOT AN
ACTUAL REBELLION.
POLITICIANS IN THIS COUNTRY ARE
ATTACKED FOR TELLING THE TRUTH.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
YOU WEIGHED IN ON THIS ELECTION.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> I AM SO EXCITED.
IT'S FUNNY.
I LOOKED MISS MELONI UP WHEN I
HEARD ABOUT HER A WEEK AGO.
I COULD NOT FIND ANY STRAIGHT UP
INFORMATION ON HER.
SHE'S A FACIST AND RACIST.
THIS IS SOMETHING I CAN RELATE
TO IT.
THEY ARE DOING THE SAME THING
ABOUT ME.
IT MAKES ME REALIZE IF THEY ARE
NOT CALLING YOU SLURS AND
ATTACKING YOU, YOU ARE PROBABLY
NOT REPRESENTING THE PEOPLE OF
YOUR COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: IT'S SO INTERESTING.
IF YOU ARE ELECTED IN ARIZONA IT
WILL BE A CHANGE.
DONALD TRUMP WAS A CHANGE.
THE VOTERS IN THIS DEMOCRACY
NEVER LEARN ANYTHING FROM THAT
REJIGS.
-- REJECTION.
WHY IS THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I CAN'T GET INTO THEIR MINDS.
I THINK OF THE MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENS OF THE WORLD AND WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN ITALY.
THE PEOPLE NETS WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN THIS COUNTRY, WE
ARE LOSING THIS COUNTRY.
THEY SAID YOU ARE NOT AFRAID OF
ANYTHING.
WHAT I AM SCARED TO DEATH OF IS
IF WE DON'T STEP AT THIS MOMENT
AND DO SOMETHING.
I AM AFRAID OF THE WORLD OUR
CHILDREN WILL LIVE IN.
>> Tucker: YOU SPENT YOUR CAREER
WORKING IN NEWS.
YOU KNOW HOW TOTALLY FRAUDULENT
IS.
>> THANK GOD F